- And I'm back.
Hanging out with David Dobrick.
My next guest prides himself
on solving problems that don't exist,
by making products nobody's looking for.
Why not?
It's always fun to see
what he comes up with.
Let's get Matt Benedetto in here.
Hey, what's up, man?
How you doing?
- I'm doing well.
How are you?
- I am so good.
I love that we've got
you, like, two times over.
This is awesome.
- Yeah, looking great.
- Okay.
All right, so say hi to
David Dobrick as well.
- Hi Matt, how are you?
Good to see you.
- I'm doing well, how are you David?
- Pretty good, pretty good.
- All right, well, David
actually loves to buy
random things online.
He just showed me, which I want both.
So we wanted him to see what you've got.
So, Matt, I understand
you've been very busy
in your studio during the pandemic, right?
- Yes, this is the unnecessary studio.
Would you like a quick tour?
- Yes.
- So, here we go.
So over here,
we've got a whole slew of 3D printers.
So, I use these to make
some of my inventions.
We have the wall of unnecessary,
where some of my inventions
end up after I'm done.
Over here, we've got my
little editing and BR station.
I've got a whole sewing station over here.
This is a laser cutter.
So I can use laser to cut,
like, metal and all sorts
of fun stuff.
- Wow, that sounds dangerous.
But, yes.
- Exactly.
- So, what have you been,
like, you're wearing one of
your latest things, right?
You said-
- I am.
So, I-
This invention came from,
sort of women talking about,
never having enough pocket
space on their pants.
So I thought, instead of two pockets,
why not have one giant
pocket across your butt?
And so, David, I know
you like to play tennis,
so, you know, maybe you could
have your tennis racket there,
ready to go, but then you
got to get some work done.
You've got your iPad,
you've got a hairbrush,
you've got a sandwich for lunch.
Everything you need, everything.
- I was just going to say,
I have had the toughest
time fitting my racket
into my pockets.
(laughs)
- I just love that, if you
knew the size of my ass,
a pocket on my ass-
(laughs)
- Well, it sort of gives
whole new meaning to,
junk in the trunk.
- Yeah, it's a lot of more.
Its a (indistinct) thing.
That's amazing.
All right, well, Matt sent David and me,
another one of his practical inventions.
It is a necklace and
I'm very curious, okay.
It's very-
It's a statement.
- We want you to have one.
It connects in the back.
- Its warm.
- And so, you know, when you're
buying some chicken nuggets,
you know, you want to get the 20 piece,
but sometimes you can't eat them all.
So, this is called the Nuggie Necklace.
So, each container magnetically comes off,
and you have a chicken nugget.
So, you can have maybe only half of it,
put the other half back, snap it back in.
- How long has this been in here?
- Yeah, I know.
- I shipped them like
four, three weeks ago.
They should be fine.
- [Kelly] Oh, they're fine.
- Thank God Nuggets don't
go bad for like, five years.
(laughs)
- I'm not even kidding you.
My kids would love this.
This is, this is amazing.
So, how is your Nuggie necklace?
Do you like it, David?
(laughs)
- Yeah, I'm obsessed with it.
I would like the Nuggie
belt too, just in case.
So I can have more Nuggets.
- Across the chest, around the waist,
just like 49 Nuggets, nonstop.
- So wait, Matt.
Wait, what's the last invention
you have for us today?
- So the very last one.
So, I just won the Webby for
the Social Weird Category.
And it was my very first award that I won.
So I thought,
I want everyone to know,
that I won an award.
I built a harness to show
off my Webby award, nonstop.
I heard that I should be
making a separate one,
that's the Emmy harness,
because I believe we have a-
- Emmy!
I did.
- Congratulations.
- I can't believe it, I'm still shocked.
I think it might've been
an accident, but it's fine.
I love that it looks like you've got
a baby Bjorn on, from a (indistinct).
It looks- from my perspective.
- So there we go.
So, the Webby harness.
On the strap, it just
says, Look at my award.
'Cause I just want everyone to know,
that I, now,
am a award winning weirdo.
- Oh my gosh, wait.
This is a real thing.
So, we're about to tape The Voice,
and I totally want to have that,
so I can put my Voice Trophies on them,
and just walk around Blake Shelton,
and just be like,
" oh, these things?"
- Put some lights on.
- Fun.
Yes, that's what I'm
going to do on The Voice.
That would be amazing.
Would you wear that harness, David?
- Again, I already have-
I already have too much.
Too much eyes on me.
- Too much eyes on me.
He likes the Nuggie neglace.
- I'd like to stay with this one.
- All right, so you,
you made an invention,
that people can buy.
What is it, Matt?
- So, yeah, so I just launched.
So, after 180 inventions over
the past year and a half,
I launched the Jigsaw Puzzle coffee table.
So, the top of the coffee table,
can't be used until you
solve the jigsaw puzzle.
So, it's sort of like, Ikea
directions on steroids.
You have to put the entire puzzle
of the coffee table together,
before you can actually use
this functional coffee too.
- Okay, well, nothing on Ikea,
but I'm just telling you,
the people that should
make directions to build
anything in life, or whoever
does the directions for Legos,
those people have it going on.
It's so easy.
Thank you so much, Matt and David.
Ya'll check out Matt's book
101 Unnecessary Inventions.
The new updated version
will be out this fall.